angela merkel hat die cdu 18 jahre lang
als parteivorsitzender angeführt sie hat
ihre partei
18 jahre lang geprägt das ist eine
außerordentliche leistung sie hat die
führung in der cdu übernommen
wie sie wissen als die partei in einer
tiefen krise war
sie wurde als erste frau in diese
aufgabe gewählt und damals auch und
immer wieder von vielen männern in der
politik auch im journalismus belächelt
oder auch für schwach erklärt angela
merkel hat das nicht nur ausgehalten
sie hat ihre partei auch anders geführt
einen neuen führungsstil geprägt und
auch eine inhaltliche neuausrichtung
veranlasst grenzwerte entscheidung der
kanzlerin
das waren 18 erfolgreiche jahre die sie
als bundeskanzlerin die partei geführt
hat in die regierung geführt hat und es
kommt jetzt darauf an dass die große
koalition wieder bessere arbeit leistet
und das ist die aufgabe
angela merkel ist nun 18 jahre
parteivorsitzende der cdu das ist eine
unglaublich lange zeit in der sie die
politik der union maßgeblich geprägt hat
insofern kann ihre entscheidungen nicht
überraschend sondern ist jetzt ein
notwendiger beitrag zur politischen
klärungsprozessen merkel selbst
sagt seit jahren parteivorsitz und
kanzlerschaft gehören zusammen so es
gibt hier im parteivorsitz ab und wir
hoffen noch sehr dass sie dann auch ihre
kanzlerschaft möglichst bald abgibt dann
auch das wäre ein großer schritt für
unser land
das erwarten wir auch letzter konsequenz
von angela merkel